estas playas del territorio francés de
martinica deberían estar llenas en esta
época del año pero este verano el
escenario cambia porque la isla entra en
su cuarto encierro con un toque de queda
ampliado con un modo de reflexión nos
pidieron que nos vacunamos antes de
venir a la isla y ahora que estamos aquí
estamos confinados así que lo vamos a
disfrutar mucho menos pavo como apoyo
entre los residentes hay una mezcla de
aceptación y de frustración y creo que
las autoridades están obligadas a tomar
medidas drásticas y no hay estudios pero
por supuesto que es lamentable que
hayamos llegado a esto pero también es
nuestra culpa
el nuevo encierro es una molestia para
mí creo que es un poco exagerado
llevamos más de un año y es demasiado
estamos cansados de esto es hora de que
se acabe martinica es una de las
regiones más afectadas de francia y
tiene dificultades para hacer frente al
número de hospitalizaciones el
ministerio de defensa francés ha
confirmado el envío de diez camas
adicionales de cuidados intensivos la
próxima semana y el despliegue de su
cuenta en médicos militares en la isla
el aumento de los casos se debe en parte
al incremento de los viajes desde
francia continental a este departamento
de ultramar con motivo de las vacaciones
de verano aunque la lentitud de la
aplicación de las vacunas también juega
su parte en la nueva ola de contagios
con sólo un 19% la isla caribeña tiene
la tasa de inoculación más baja de
francia